can covet vaccines help long-haulers
with symptoms
uh and you know i saw and i don't think
we ended up talking about it on a live
stream
i saw an article not a peer-reviewed
article like new york times maybe
that made this claim and
i can't make sense of how this could
possibly be the case
well i mean i think unfortunately
this is the other
side of your interfering with a complex
system
so you've got a complex system it's now
had
a novel input the coronavirus
and now you're going to add another
novel input could that novel input
disrupt whatever is going on
so if the covid virus let's say that the
story that we understand about covet is
correct and that the body clears covid
but some people keep having symptoms
which could be the result of damaged
tissue
it could be the result of a
miscalibration
don't know but um something about that
system
let's say that long coveid
is autoimmune in nature yep
and then you dump a vaccine on it that
causes production of the spike protein
which then occupies the antibodies and
t cells that are targeted at covid
detaining them
from screwing up the body through
autoimmunity is there anything
is there any reason to think though the
spike protein that would be produced by
these vaccines
rna or dna would be would jump to the
head of the line
um in terms of occupying the immune
system no as opposed to just like
so it's like a density dependence
argument right if your body is producing
antibodies and t cells that are
attacking tissues that are not infected
then dumping something that occupies
some of those t cells that wastes their
time
yeah right could be positive so i'm not
saying that i think this is true
and part of the problem is you know it's
i'm starting to see discussion and i
think um
it is important that we have it about
what fraction of long covet is long
covered
and what fraction of long covet is
something else i don't want to call it
uh hypochondria
but people are too what if
if if it might not exactly be long
coverage it might not exactly be
hypochondria what other
what kinds of things are you imagining
well have you heard
let's put it through discussion of
everybody is
um involved in some novel way of living
now right i know that i periodically
wake up
and i feel oh goodness that feels like i
might be getting sick
and i start wondering about covid and
then
i figure out that it's not covered and i
get over it how many times does that
happen before i ever heard of covid
and so like misattribution even perhaps
like okay
complexity a suite of symptoms i know i
had the thing the suite of symptoms
broadly matches
this description and we have a name for
this and if i name it this then i get
that then i have credibility you know it
doesn't have to be any kind of
um in there it doesn't have to be
intentionality there doesn't have to be
deviousness
all right in any way absolutely it's a
complex system
and it's a relief to have a name for a
thing when you when you didn't and if
you've got an easy name to default to
perhaps that's what you do um let's put
it this way
you've got some large number of people
who have long coveted
yeah okay let's say long covet is
absolutely real and some fraction of
them just simply have it
yeah okay and some fraction of them have
got some new pathology that just
is coincident in time with them having
had coveted yeah or
was kovitt pushed something that was in
the offing
into an active form and it's just a
casual
connection that really has very little
to do with covid or
we've also heard very credible stories
of um latent pathologies that re-emerge
due to covid such as mononucleosis
yeah so anyway there are a lot of things
tied up in here
yeah so um holly holly mathnard says
long cove it is incentivized on social
media major attention political points
scoring for teen
blue right and so you would imagine
that some some fraction of long covid is
clearly not long covered right what
fraction is it
and how do you sort between that which
is truly new and mysterious and that's
which
isn't yeah and the answer is nobody
knows we're doing a terrible job with
covet itself
with respect to what it actually does
what it responds to
um so yeah no and i do think i mean this
is this is sort of where we were and
what i see up here both from holly and
other people is
um that we've now got a culture um
that um that that
raises people in the estimation of
unfortunately many social groups
um if they say they are weak if they say
they are sick
or victims or you know still
dealing with something that they just
need help with you know and this you
know this is unfortunately this is
this to the degree that this is
identifiable
um on average by political party it's
more a democratic position
yeah um and to the degree that it's
identifiable
by sex on average it's more of a female
position
and like i don't like that either of
those things are true but they are
um and you know and we have a move to
basically celebrate
that sort of thinking as opposed to
self-sufficiency and pull yourself up by
your bootstraps and try to figure it out
and try to
you know try to make yourself better and
be anti-fragile
and um you know all of all of those
things that i just said
will help not just you know yes all of
us if more people did that but also
every single individual who does
no question um it also
and this goes to your point about this
being
more on the blue side than the the red
side yeah um
but in some sense the
marxist instincts that exist over on the
left
um build in a reward for neediness yeah
and so
in some sense this is being manifest in
a medical context and what we have is
some
kind of uh munchausen
thing and it is very important not to
say oh
there's a lot of fakery around this some
of it's unintentional therefore it's not
a thing
and the problem the real victims are the
ones who do have something and it's
getting lost in a
cloud frankly that's exactly what we see
with trans yeah right
and so we'll get we'll get there um i
really do want to get to those questions
all those sort of mid-20s in my list
here
um that you know just because
all the noisy people and the vast
majority of you know in the case of
long-haul cover i don't know but it may
be
that the vast majority of people who are
getting all the attention are you know
are
not experiencing a thing related to
kovid and there's still a real real
thing
and at this point in you know you said
it's not culture wars it's about
existential threat but you know
i'll say culture wars for the moment i
feel very much that way with regard to
trans
we know it's a real thing yeah we you
know there there are real trans people
yeah as we said many many times but but
the thing getting all the air time
is um largely not that yeah in that case
there is
at least a natural distinction it's not
a hard boundary but there's a
distinction between trans and trans
activism yeah and that the problem is
when the two things are synonyms there's
long covedom
long covid you know what do you do um
right i do think there was a period
before long coved was
famous and i was watching the long
covered subreddit
and so these were people were having
trouble getting the attention of the
medical community and
very few in the outside world had even
heard of it yet and so
my sense is well most of that was quite
real
and i feel i know i feel this way
actually about a lot of the autoimmune
diseases
um like for instance fibromyalgia yeah
right like if i if i didn't happen to
know someone
who did their literally their phd
dissertation on fibromyalgia
there was a very good chance that i
would still feel like what whatever
you know this is some you know it's it
it's it's an attention getting
you know thing that is really hard to
pinpoint that has a whole set of
symptoms that you don't have to have
almost any of them to be diagnosed and
it's mostly women
as a lot of these autoimmune diseases
are and so you know is that
physiological or is that personality but
um but no as it turns out there's a ton
of reality to you know modernity
creating autoimmune disorders
and that happens to be one of them and
it may be that women are more
susceptible because they have a much
more
complex puzzle with respect to immunity
and pregnancy interacting
so maybe the therapy systems are tuned
in a way
that predisposes towards autoimmunity
i would say though in some sense the
fault
or a large part of it is with the
medical community which
does not properly distinguish between we
have the distinction
between a pathology and a syndrome right
and the problem is guess what it's a
complex system
what's a syndrome it's something with a
bunch of overlapping symptoms but you
get that anytime
you have a cascade of 20 things that
happen in a row
anything that intervenes at one of these
stage causes all of the pathologies
downstream of it so
is fibromyalgia a thing or is it
four things right well and this is true
for so
separated sorry this is true for so many
things that are for instance the dsm
like schizophrenia you know multiple
things
autism probably multiple things and you
know some of those things aren't real
things
yeah right like you know the the thing
we've named includes all of this
and there are you know maybe five
distinct ideologies including
yeah that's not a thing like what you've
got isn't isn't isn't even part of this
this thing that we're trying to describe
right and in fact we need
you know because every single time you
have a pathology
some fraction of the people who say they
have it
are there for psychological reasons
rather than
physiological reasons yeah basically
that does not discredit
the physical phenomenon at all it's just
it comes with the territory right and so
we ought to have that
category and you know i don't like
hypochondria
as that category because that suggests a
kind of global
phenomenon but basically there is a
human analog to what we call placebo and
someday we're going to have to talk
about placebo because
it's a very interesting and not what
people think
kind of topic but um but the point is
just
as a phony drug can fool you
into uh reporting that you're better um
a person can falsely understand
themselves
to be ill yeah right and that that's
just simply
inherent in the territory and anytime
you're dealing with syndrome stuff
it's going to get all tangled right hey
guys
that was a clip from our monthly private
q a that you can get access to
at my heather heing's patreon and you
can also get access there to
all of the past paid subscriber content
so please consider joining us there
did you mention that these private q as
are the key
to living a better life and living to
tell the tale i forgot to do that
these private q and a's are in fact the
key to living a better life and what
living to tell the tale living to tell
the tale
go ahead live to tell the tale join us
there see ya